be open so today's book update video I
want to talk about what happened on my
book writing day I wasn't able to write
anything because I had a really special
event with Stephen Kelly at the CN Tower
which was one of our landmarks here in
Canada and it was a really important
event and I've talked about before
there's something that is really huge
then it's worth changing your schedule
around four and he's a CEO of sage it's
a multi-billion dollar company tens of
thousands of employees and we did a
hangout he came to Toronto to meet with
me and do something together at the top
of the scene tower so it's pretty cool
took up the whole day and I want to talk
about being open because usually when I
work with brands on deals I have
companies say you can only say this and
you can't say that and you should be you
know make sure you don't ask these kinds
of questions and when I went to the CN
Tower they sent me an email to say make
sure that you don't say this is the
world's tallest google hangout and all
of these stipulations of what I can't
say that this is so ridiculous like
first of all I wasn't even thinking
about saying that and second of all why
wouldn't you want me to say that so I'm
helping promote what you're doing right
is just ridiculous and then I get an
email from Stephen Kelly's team to say
it's a complete opposite to say hey if
there's anybody who's using our software
that they're having issues with problems
with complaints about make sure it makes
it into the live hangout right the exact
opposite of what the CN Tower was saying
and I absolutely respect and admire that
because you don't know what kind of
questions that you're going to get us in
a live session and he wanted them he
wanted to make sure we gave them to him
and you got the CN Tower being total
douche bags and saying what we can and
can't say anyway I think you got to be
open you have to be open with your
business you gotta be open with your if
you write in the book your book writing
process that's why I'm doing this you
guys can see every week the behind the
scenes what goes into creating the book
and so I encourage you to listen to your
customers and encourage you to get
feedback from the people who watch you
on YouTube when in social media and
don't be afraid of that yes it someone
would be negative some of them is is a
lesson for you to be able to get better
and provide a better experience to the
people that you're serving and that only
comes when you're listening and you're
open so bitter of rent today yesterday
was an insane day CN Tower I had to deal
with four different security
tax and didn't have you know anything
ready for us when we got there and just
a huge headache but the session was
awesome we could link that up here you
guys can check it out is super fun to do
so when i get to your questions that's
what we're doing here so first up Jer
eyes what percentage of the book would
you see as complete first draft is
complete then i make that announcement
yet I put it on social but don't think I
talked about it yeah so the first draft
is complete so excited super happy and
now we've got to do some editing right
it's going back looking at what needs to
be improved edited at it but I'm so so
happy that the first draft is complete
and now we gotta sit dating process I
don't know what percentage that is but a
hundred percent on the draft and zero
percent on the editing next yogesh 85
fake it before you make it ready to buy
your book so I appreciate the support
for the book and terms of the fake it
before you make a message it's been
reference to my video last week we can
link that up where I was talking about
whenever I am doing things I try to
imagine that important people are
watching right whenever I'm making these
videos already imagine that millions of
people are watching it and whenever the
radio show imagine that my mentors are
listening it ups the stakes and makes
you do a better job I would caution you
though because I don't consider that
faking it until I'm making it I don't
want the advice to come across as I
think you should try to be somebody else
I think you should try to fake it that
you're this expert when you're not
that's not what I'm saying what I'm
trying to encourage you to do is be the
best version of yourself what would
version you look like when you have this
live broadcast to millions of people be
that person it's still you it's not
faking it trying to be somebody else I
really wanted to draw that line because
i'm actually not a huge fan of faking it
until you make it and I don't want that
to be the message that I put across and
so I apologize for the confusion um
before it's more being the best version
of yourself and again just imagining
that I have all these people who are
paying attention to me it just makes you
do a better job it increases the
importance it's not just you sitting
there in front of a computer right in
the book it's not just you sit in front
of a camera making a video right it's
just me and Jason here making a video
but i know that it's being broadcast to
a lot of people and so that makes me
want to do a better job next aiders
thanks for another great message I
appreciate that I would really love to
hear how you will be marketing your
book once it's written I think that
would be a great spinoff I would also
love to see anything that was edited out
both are great ideas cool yeah so I am
kind of thinking about what do I do with
this series once the book has been
submitted and I don't have to write
anymore so those are the two that I'm
going with how do i market it how I
building up the campaign to get the word
out and then also if something gets left
off the editing floor doing something
fun with it so I'll keep you posted if
you have other ideas things you'd like
to see let me know in the comments
because I do pay attention to those and
maybe we could do something next yo and
eyes are nice message but are you
applying it yourself is this the kind of
video quality you put out when you know
the big shots are watching you yeah
absolutely first of all I only talk
about things that I'm actually doing I'm
only talking about things that I have
knowledge about I don't I don't come on
and try to talk about things that I have
no idea about and I'm just honestly
sharing my opinions on how something
should be done and so whenever i'm
sharing advice it's because i'm using it
I've sent some of these videos to people
in the publishing world and to
entrepreneurs that I look up to and to
my mentors and to my coaches to look at
and it's way less about the quality I'm
happy to send out an iPad video to
someone who is important because it's
way less about the quality of the video
and way more about the content of it
right so this one I wasn't able I didn't
have time yesterday zoo I'm here so
Jason is filming it with me here and you
may say well that that's higher quality
right that's that's a great video to
send out but if I sucked on camera Jason
couldn't save me right jason has a lot
of skills but he could not save me if I
sucked on camera where I could produce a
way better video coming off of my iPad
then he could bringing in some newbie
who has no idea what they're talking
about right so the content is always
going to be super important and it's
it's the mindset right going into every
video everything I make its having that
mindset that this is going to be seen by
millions of people and my mentors and
then just adjust your focus and so yeah
absolutely I do it all the time and I
everything I talked about with you guys
as part of being open is stuff I
actually believe in and I'm doing myself
in my business next chef Matt
congratulations for your book I'm ready
to buy it thank you appreciate that man
next up Malik couple questions I find
writing for video to be actually harder
than writing the book I think it's
because things have to be so much
tighter in a video it's different to
compare the two mediums because books
require much higher word count but I'm
curious if you have found writing for
your book easier than writing for video
I'm the complete opposite I write very
little for my videos right I'm writing
nothing for this I just read the
question and I am answering it there is
ZERO writing that's happening for most
of the other videos we've done a little
bit of research and so I might for the
top 10 i might read it i might be kind
of memorizing part of a script for the
nth special series on the end of it i'm
just going off some r if I might write
like one or two words down I might write
failure down or or being a shame or
striving for success or whatever it is
whatever the topic is just as a
something to jog my memory and that's it
so I don't write anything down for those
ones and I find writing for a book a lot
harder for those reasons how did you
identify and contact the people that you
interviewed and profiled in the book
identifying them was hard the strategies
that i'm talking about not many people
are using them and so the i did a couple
things one i did a google news alert so
anytime certain key phrases that i'm
looking for were mentioned in a business
context i would flag them and be able to
see them and that introduced me to some
people and to just pay attention like
when you have a goal things become much
clearer to you i found some people just
by going to a bookstore and seeing what
books are being written and now that I
knew what I was looking for I found
these people and so just being aware I
think helps and then setting the news
alerts help me up as well and talking to
people right I'm looking for this like
tell people what you're looking for if
your specific right not just I'm looking
for somebody to interview but I'm
looking for entrepreneurs in the
manufacturing industry to interview as
an example it immediately lets me think
of can I help you or not can I give you
off to somebody in terms of reaching out
to them mostly it was through Twitter I
love Twitter as a way to reach out to
people people typically check their app
messages a lot of entrepreneurs are on
my the people i'm interviewing
entrepreneurs a lot of entrepreneurs are
on a lot of executives are on as well a
lot of them aren't very popular they're
using twitter but they don't really know
how to use twitter they're on twitter
because somebody
told them they need to be on Twitter and
so they really check all of their app
messages and it's a great way to build a
reach out if I was trying to read some
of these people through traditional
routes picking up a phone and dealing
with secretary after secretary trying to
find their email address somehow or
guess at it be a hard lengthy process so
as of right now towards my favorite way
to reach out to people as you've been
writing this book have you gotten lots
of ideas for other books I ask because
that happens to me which makes it
difficult to finish any writing project
because I want to start with a new idea
before even complete the original one ah
yes I've had other ideas for different
books some of them might be a book some
of them might be a video series I have
ideas all the time I have a list of
ideas that I want to work on I think
what helps in this case is one
identifying the project you working on
right like I have a list of ideas and
then I have lists of my priorities here
the projects that I'm working on that
are important to me i need to get these
done before moving on other things that
list changes if the things I'm working
on aren't interesting to me anymore
right if I look at that list I don't
want to do those things and that happens
for a week at a time and I you know what
I just gotta drop it drop and move on
something that you are excited about
also I have a team of people who are
helping me and they've removed a lot of
the pain points that I don't enjoy and
help me see focus and push me to to get
it done right and so I find that if
you're just doing things on your own and
you have committed to anybody else it
could be a lot harder to complete the
project or if you have committed to
someone else you much more likely to
follow through just like going to the
gym right you commit to somebody else
you might more likely to go and finish
Lynn just rides great questions I'm
anxious to read the book Thank You Lynn
for the support Paula it's so nice to
watch another person's dream become a
reality that's cool i like that you're
happy with the journey and me sharing it
that's part of being open back to the
message at the top i'd say maybe there's
a teachable lesson here for you as well
that people might want to watch your
journey you're enjoying watching mine
and learning from it and seeing my
stumbles and failures and also the
victories and successes and if you're
enjoying that then chances are people
would also enjoy watching you in what
you're doing whether you're doing a
video through youtube you're writing
blog posts doing tweets on facebook
people like being part of the journey
people like be able to help out offer
pins advice learn things from them and
so I would HIGHLY encourage
you Paula and I'll and everybody
watching to start to document your store
and share it and you may think people
don't care about me people are
interesting to me but they will and
you'd be surprised and helps keep you
accountable help you get you on track
and I think most importantly can help
inspire other people to do something
great as well two more paul chinn i will
buy your book definitely I've been
learning something daily thanks thank
you Paul appreciate that last up
revolution 97 I'm 18 and all I do is
watch a listener motivational speakers
audiobook successful entrepreneurs but I
feel like I'm doing nothing big yet to
reach my goals kind of upsetting what
can I do to change is feeling the keys
to start doing start taking action you
can you can think about things as much
as you want you can read and listen and
watch videos you know I love you to
provide videos for you guys you will the
watch and get inspired from and
motivated from and get ideas from but I
don't want you sitting at home just
watch my videos all day long right that
doesn't make me happy what makes me
happy is you go in and doing something
with that advice and wisdom and
inspiration so whatever gets you all
pumped up if it's something in the
morning that you listen to tony robbins
or you watch ants presso or a top 10 or
this series whatever that gets you fired
up great then take action and as long as
you are not taking action and just
thinking about it then you're never
going to be happy and in all the
motivational books and all that stuff is
not going to help you until you actually
start doing something so make your list
of things that you want to work on and
then find a small way to start doing it
don't make it something so big that's
say I'm going to reach for the stars and
you don't know how to go from here to
here it's finally have that big goal but
then what's your next step like what can
you do today the next time you find
yourself super motivated and excited all
pumped up what can you do right now
don't leave the site of a goal without
taking some kind of immediate action
towards attaining it and so that's what
I would do I would start taking insane
action find the things that you're
excited about and whenever you feel
motivated you're out there doing
something on that action if you want to
make any of the people that you're
listening to Tony Robbins and Les Brown
and me and whoever you're listening to
you want to make them happy we get
fulfilled by seeing that you took our
advice and you did something to make the
world a better place so that's it start
taking action so thank you guys lots of
questions I love to know what you think
about being open i love to answer your
questions on that for next week and if
you
have any thoughts questions comments
about my book your book the book writing
process any other questions you might
have leave them below and I'll answer
them in next week's video thank you so
much for watching can change believe and
I'll see you soon